okay so the topic today is can Muslims
prove Muhammad is a true Prophet so what
would make you believe that Muhammad is
true Prophet so the Quran makes claims
like I said to the previous caller it
says that Jesus mentioned off men to
come after him um so if I can find where
Jesus mentioned that I definitely
believe that that he's a prophet um the
Quran says that I can find him you know
mentioned in the Torah and the gospel so
if I found Muhammad mentioned in the
Torah and the gospel I'd believe it the
Quran says that it aligns with with the
previous scriptures the Torah the gospel
of the psalm so if I found that the
Quran was in perfect alignment with the
previous scriptures I'd consider it to
be you know an extension of um you know
God's words right yeah you know if if no
one if no one was actually able to make
anything like it I would definitely like
consider it like yeah wow that might be
something okay so your first point uh
was that this Bible verse regarding
Ahmed so like I don't understand is this
like your only way verifying and you
also said about the alignment so do you
not really understand that in Islamic
belief we believe that the Bible was not
perfectly preserved yeah see I I know
that that's what like Muslims tend to
say that's what Muslims tend to believe
but that's not believe that's what say
what we were T that's yeah those are
shakes that are lying to you because
that's not what the Quran say don't say
that because they're not lying to us
that's lit what we were taught and
knowledgeable than you well that's you
can say that but we can you know have
the discussion and and see but what I'm
saying is this is this okay then
uh I'm saying something the shakes teach
the shakes teach you something that the
Quran doesn't that's okay can you can
you prove to me that the are wrong in
any way I just want to put yeah for sure
yeah so if they're saying that the Quran
uh that the right is not preserved right
if I were to pull up the
Quran so this is what it says let's pull
the Quran let's go to vers
1574 so 7157 okay
7157 okay which translation is this if
you can specify uh this is halali and
Khan halali andali and Khan okay this is
unusual all right so it says those who
follow the messenger the prophet who can
neither read or right now I'm going to
skip the parentheses okay because that
that's not in the actual verse it's not
in Arabic so I'm skip whatever is in
right so those who follow the messenger
the prophet who can neither read nor
write whom they find written with them
in the Torah and the inil the gospel so
this verse says that the Torah and the
gospel are with the Jews and Christians
they have it during muham at one point
at one point the the as mentioned the in
the verse the inil was a real book that
could be followed but as I said again
are sh presently like to this day and
maybe sh even a couple Generations back
they say that it wasn't preserved at one
point if you believed in the in that was
revealed to M or you'd be considered a
Muslim but we it's got changed wait can
I finish my point can I finish my point
no so we believe where was I I say yeah
so say
otherwise this verse practically proved
nothing and that's about it okay so
according to this verse it doesn't say
that the Torah and the gospel was at one
point with them it says that it is with
them right find written with written
with them in the Torah and the gospel so
it's with them currently right uh wait
where where did where did currently come
from so it says whom they find written
with them with them in the Torah and the
gospel does this specify tense can you
go up to the Arabic so we can just read
the Arabic
really quickly just go up to the Arabic
because I think more
explanatory okay so this not this not
specify any type of tense it's talking
about the Jews and Christians in the
time of Muhammad is it not no so then
who is it talking about it's talking
about the people where when the book was
preserved but it it says that they can't
it's if it's talking about when when it
was preserved and you're saying this is
not a Muhammad's time then that means
these people are dead but it says that
those who follow the messenger the
prophet who can neither read nor write
so who's the prophet that can neither
read nor write how can they be following
the messenger who can neither read nor
write if he didn't come until after they
died how could they follow him so I'm
not disregarding the fact that they
could they could have been a preserved
scripture at the time of Muhammad but
I'm speaking about present Day present
day there is no we have no Bibles with
us that are perfectly preserved I I
never said that the Bible of Muhammad's
time could have been pres according to
this verse at the time of Muhammad there
was a preserved in and there was a
preserved Torah but what I said from the
beginning was that at our time there's
none of this let's go with that now so
we understand that in Muhammad's time
the seventh century in the seventh
century those who follow Muhammad yeah
the Torah and the gospel was preserved
at least in the seventh century
Muhammad's time y That's Muhammad's time
Muhammad's time is the seventh century
that's when he came so in the seventh
century the gospel and the Torah was
preserved now this is why this is
important because we have what existed
before the seventh century before
Muhammad's time we have the Torah we
have the gospel and we have the
Psalms that means that whatever Muhammad
was talk what the Quran was talking
about is what we have so how do you know
that there hasn't been changed in any
way like how do you know there was
multiple versions can you prove that how
do you know that what you're speaking
about is the same as what Muhammad is
speaking about well it's it's it's
simple the Quran talks about the Torah
and the gospel that's with the Jews and
the Christians well guess what just read
open the verse I want people to see it
okay sure talking about the Torah and
the gospel that's with the Jews and the
Christians now
interestingly find written with them
with them right where is Jews and
Christian what what group had the Torah
and the gospel it's Islamic book we
believe it's a Islamic holy book The is
wrong if you believe in the Trinity it's
wrong what group had the Torah and the
gospel as I said before the Torah and
the gospel is an Islamic book and you
believe that Jews are Islamic people
right and Christians no the Jewish
belief is not nothing like Islam wasn't
Jesus a Jew and Moses a Jew and all them
Jews weren't the prophets Jews no they
were Muslim oh my gosh they believe you
probably don't know what a Jew is so
brother a a Jew is is is an Israelite
Ben Israel that's what a Jew is okay so
um the Jews Ben Israel they had the
Torah right okay go and then they also
received the inil through Jesus Jesus
came with the inil and so his followers
and people that came after him followed
the in yeah but we believe they deviated
it they changed the word of him I know I
know you believe they deviated however
they didn't deviate until after
Muhammad's time apparently no there
could have been there could have been
deviations there there's nothing that
proves that they wasn't could more than
one version there Dev brother if there's
deviations in the Torah and the gospel
then the Quran is saying that you can
find Muhammad in the corrupted Torah and
gospel wait they could find Muhammad in
the corrupted gospel uh I didn't say
that I said there could have been more
than one there could have been false
Bibles and the actual don't I won't say
the Bible there could have been false
inels and real inels you know like there
could have been people that tried
spreading misinformation at the time of
Muhammad which could have been false
uhel that you guys probably are
following today and there of course
according to this verse there is real
angels saying I'm I'm not the same thing
okay so now this what is this is what we
have to do now in Islam the religion of
what if you have to say well excuse me
excuse me excuse me what do you me
ReliOn of what if don't disect My
Religion ever again dude relax I'm Cal
down you don't to be so sensitive what
I'm saying is when I
say interrupting me while I'm speaking
please the relig the religion of what if
and the religion of could be is because
Muslims like yourself continue to
disregard what your Quran says and you
guys what I'm talking please I didn't
interrupt you just don't disrespect me
again and I this what it is if you can't
take it then you should drop this is how
we talk so you talk with disrespect so
this if you if you think this is
disrespect leave the religion of what if
yeah the religion of what if the
religion of what if and the religion of
yeah there we go all you have all you
have is it could be this or it could be
that what if this or what if that you
don't have any substance to what you say
you have nothing to stand on you have no
so no
proof you're saying that I have no
substance so this is what I need you to
do no
no what is your Quran say that there's
different inals out there there's a fake
inil or give evidence of a fake inil out
there go ahead okay no no you did
understand I trying to say I was trying
to say how do you know that the Bible
the Quran is talking about is the same
one you guys have how do you know it not
deviated okay all right fair enough
exact show you the same thing watch
you're saying exactly watch this I'mma
show you the same think I showed the
last Muslim watch this ab and I'mma show
you more too you know this why you'll
see why I'm called Shake logic you're
GNA see in a second you're not Shake
logic never ever see that again we'll
see we'll see your name is you gonna see
why they call me shake logic Hab don't
call me Habi I'm not your brother and
never disam againi doesn't mean brother
Aki is brother I didn't call you brother
Habibi in my region of Arabia it's
basically means brother so don't ever
try Habi I'm going call you Habibi if I
want to I'm going call you so I can call
you whatever I want to right I should
call you probably iban I'm going call
you um son as well okay son look at what
this is this is your Quran chter 5: 45
you see it 545 it says and we ordained
therein for them Life For Life eye for
eye nose for nose ear for ear tooth for
tooth and wounds for wounds right here
over here in my Bible to the left Watch
what it says tell me if it sounds
familiar but if there is harm then you
shall pay Life For Life eye for an eye
tooth for tooth hand for hand foot for
foot burn for B burn wound for wound
stripe for stripe sound familiar so what
your question does it sound familiar
yeah that's the question there are a
couple of similar words and yeah I could
say it's guess what here's the important
part your Quran says we ordained therein
for them talking about the Torah we
ordained in the Tor can can you go in
Arabic I think I think I understand it
more in Arabic there it is okay good son
good son um
okay so you can go back to English now
all right cool so you see here How It
quotes my Bible I wouldn't say it quotes
but I say the verse similar so when it
says we ordained therein talking about
the Torah right we can find we can find
this in the Torah right we can find this
verse in the Torah uh so do you realize
where the verse starts from you're not
answering the question my brother when
Allah says we ordained in it for them
and then it says this life for Life ey
for n y y y we can
the right sure go ahead yeah we can find
this in the Torah right we can find
um it doesn't say that where does it say
that what ises what what does this mean
right here wait I don't really use the
translation so I can just can you give
me the numbers this
Isa
45a 4 use my us translation and I can
give you read read I read Arabic but I
think I think so people so the viewers
can understand more so I can put it into
better words bro come on man I thought
you you know translate the Arabic for me
I'm not that advanced yet if you why do
you keep telling me to go back to the
Arabic if you can't you can't read so I
can personally understand it but if I I
can't put the Arabic into words
understand okay how about this let me
help does it say and we ordained yeah it
it say we ordained for them in the Torah
very good good so we ordained for them
in the Torah and then it quotes It
quotes the Torah Life For Life eye for
an eye nose for nose ear for ear it says
that this is in the Torah so we should
be able to go to the Torah and find this
right not the present day Torah but the
Torah of okay so if we can find this in
the present day Torah then this means
that we still have the Torah right no
that's that's another that's another
like that's
another I think I think right now I
should call the Christianity what if
because everything you're saying is like
you act
like me again I have to because you're
not you're not dealing with this here
you you can find it in
the me son so can you find this in today
son I I know you want to get kicked but
you're you're a humiliation I'm not
trying to get kic you cutting me and we
already stated that in front of
thousands of people you've been put in
your place I'm not getting I'm actually
very relaxed right now oh it gets good
so can you find this in the tour relax
right now and can you just tell me you
won't cut me answer the question you
find yes or no so if we read the verse
again we ordained for them in the Torah
so I can we find it in the Torah yes or
no can you can you not cut me please
like it's again I you're embarrassing
yourself you're answer question can you
find it in the Torah yes or no um Son
thank you very much we ordained for them
in the tah so I believe at the time of
Muhammad I don't care what you believe
can you find you stop cussing me bum no
you're cutting yourself boy you're
cutting yourself hey watch your tone
we're using Allah's words to cut you me
and Allah are cutting
you you're bleeding from the wrist I
think I think
um I think you're like somehow
somehow you speak Arabic can you find
this in the Tor is can you find this in
the Torah in the mham Tor yes you can
okay so got you so guess what you can
find it in the Torah during Muhammad's
time so if I can find it in the Torah in
my time then that means that my Torah is
the same as Muhammad's Torah right no no
how does that make sense why not why not
so uh let's L that's that verse kept in
there other vers
changed let's say that verse was kept
but the other verses have been changed
man get out of get out of here clown
absolute you guys are an absolute
embarrassment but I love when guys like
you come up because embarr when I
humiliating your type the prideful and
arrogant ones you guys are the funnest
to humiliate I promise you you're the
funnest to cook you're the funnest to
boil in the pot I have the most fun
boiling your type then I do the rest I
have no problem with it now you gave us
a beautiful clip thank you so much